nous sommes le 4 janvier 2021 et voilà
ce qui pourrait être le premier dérapage
de la rentrée politique
un petit placement de produit qui n'est
pas passée inaperçue c'est la ministre
marlène schiappa qui est au coeur de la
tourmente après qu'un message et était
postée sur son compte instagram
un message qui a étonné des internautes
puisqu'il faisait état de la promotion
d'un lissage brésilien
merci adriano et rassemble highness
brasil pour ce lissage qui répare les
cheveux et va donc nous permettre de
gagner de précieuses minutes avant
chaque match 9 un message de promotion
qui a fait beaucoup réagir pour eux une
mine et n'a pas à se prêter à ces
placements de produits récurrents chez
des influenceurs et autres stars du net
très vite face aux critiques le compte
de la députée est passé en privé mais
même si on peut d'identifier dans la
vidéo l'entourage de marlène schiappa
insisté sur le fait que ce poste était
faux nous maintenons formellement le
démenti c'est un fake
si on peut éviter de relayer ce genre de
chose qui lui vaut une dizaine d'
insulte une dépense qui a peu convaincu
les internautes le salon contacté par la
presse indique ne pas avoir payé pour
cette publication mais confirme que
marlène schiappa est bel et bien une
cliente du salon alors marlène schiappa
fait un placement de produit comprenez
vous la polémique son coiffeur et notre
témoin du jour et va nous dire toute la
vérité sur cette affaire
c'est énorme c'est une vrai sport et
c'est le sujet du jour
mais sachez que façon et on va le dire
basso toutes les émissions voulez vous
invité aujourd'hui reçu beaucoup
d'appels mais ils ont reçu peu après
c'est tout le monde voulait avoir sur
cette histoire de lissage des sachez
déjà que marlène schiappa n'a pas fait
un placement de produit parce que c'est
ce qu'elle a dit donc comme on a pu
l'entendre dans cette affaire alors
soraya voûte est la responsable en
beauté de ces vite démarré parce que
cette histoire me marlène schiappa ça
démarre par vous qu'est ce qui s'est
passé exactement alors allez l assister
à l'émission elle était invitée dans
l'émission ce qui avant les vacances
bateau et donc elle vient en loge
oui je commence à la hauteur et le
tribunal
vu que ça c'est une vraie histoire c'est
donc beaucoup moins a raconté marlene sa
part voilà jusqu'ici tout va bien tout
va bien on discute on parle de la pluie
du beau temps non nana là aussi vous
avez un problème de pointe et c'est
véridique ans que jean raconte à feu
voilà vous avez un problème je connais
quelqu'un de notre problème de court
jean pierre je me sens le dossier est
donc après je me donne je donne at sans
natation mais n'annoncera que c'est à
elle que j'ai donné le numéro de vincent
d'accord mais si l'armée est là elle met
le doigt dans un engrenage allen chapin
ministre dé la vraiment mini du
gouvernement met le doigt dans un
engrenage et la de coiffure aux
coiffures celle escalade de l'horreur
donc là vinsot marlène schiappa vous
appelle de la part de soi rien
exactement c'est diane même qui vous
appellent ou son assistante
ces mêmes en dirait elle mène n'allait
déjà pas c'est le même qui nous
appellent tout à fait et marlène
schiappa vous demande un rendez-vous est
ponctionnée vous dire tu veux pas voir
sa voisine de zéro c'est pour un lissage
[Musique]
occ laval n ya pas arrive au salon se
fait coiffer donc là vous voyez marley
de chapa la ministre arrivée c'est vous
qui lui fait le lissage brésilien
c'est mon associé à patras haussier
adriano exactement qui s'est également
occupé de moi donc adriano fait de
lissage brésilien est ce qu adriano a vu
quelque chose de bizarre pendant six as
possible non variante partie donc j'ai à
nouveau des pointes mais plus à la fin
la marlène schiappa il nu dans votre
salon il est resté combien de temps
12h30 deux heures à saint denis sa
maison tout en travaillant
la polémique c'est que marlène schiappa
a publié ce ce poste regardez voilà
brice age origins bien merci pour six
indiens qui répare les cheveux et va
donc me permettre de gagner de
précieuses minutes avant chaque match
final ils sont bien sûr la question tout
le monde se pose c'est est-ce que c'est
un placement de produit ou pas donc
est-ce que vous lui avez fait
gratuitement
ce lissage brésilien ça coûte combien
lissage brésilien sommes indépendants
mais on ne ressent que ces 150 euros 150
euros d'accord je sais que dans mon cas
c'est 15 et je dois le dire et je vous
jure que c'est vrai moi je n'ai pas fait
de placements produits et adriano n'a
pas voulu que je paye je dis non mais je
dis la vérité mais vous dis c'est quoi
vos mais le che mon cul c'est pas le
moment où on est on est en plein dans
quelle est donc la marlène schiappa at
elle payé son lit ça j'suis bien sûr
elle l'a pays bien sûr est ce que vous
l'avez pas dit est-ce que adriano n'a
pas essayé de lui dire non mais attendez
vous êtes une amie de surya moi c'est ce
qui m'a dit même si tu en as vite sur un
gars franchement tu pars sans payer moi
bien entendu vous me connaissez je suis
mes affaires
merci marlène schiappa s qui lui a
proposé de ne pas payer ou pas non non
non non non parce que de par la position
match a pas on pouvait pas se permettre
de proposer ce genre de gratuité entre
guillemets et deux autres thoniers une
polémique on ne voulait pas alors on va
voir la vidéo sur un stack à poster
marlène schiappa noyau vous posera la
question fatidique dans un instant
regardez la vidéo qui a été posté on
voit une femme de dos tourné la tête
comme dans une pub pour les shampoings
c'est bien marlène schiappa les votants
marlène schiappa qui était très très
heureuse de son nissan brésilien rai et
je crois que vous nous avez amené la
facture exactement
regardez rituel renaissance marlène
schiappa donc la facture 150 euros voilà
dont la tva
donc vous avez fait payer 150 euros à
marier de sa part qu'il a fait donc elle
a payé
donc ce n'était pas un placement de
produits ou les ai pas dit je refais
gratuitement le lissage pour que tu me
fasses un petit placement de produit
après exactement non donc vous êtes
clint il faut savoir que toute façon que
la stratégie de notre société fait qu'
on n'a jamais payé en six ans
d'existence on n'a jamais payé une
influence aux mais même une influence us
dont ses deux métiers d'accor
on n'a jamais mis le doigt dans
l'engrenage de mon billet d influence
donc sûrement pas avec malaysia pas en
tant que ministre pour faire un bon
tarif aujourd'hui dans le monde des
influenceurs et d'instagram entre
guillemets quand vous faites un
placement de produit vous avez obligé de
préciser quand vous êtes payé ou non et
à l'inversé quand c'est gratuit vous dit
ceci n'est pas un placement de produit
et la marlène schiappa pour le coup elle
a été un peu naïf parce que la manière
dont ces rédigé ça ressemble un
placement de produit fiscal mais là je
fais alors ouais là elle aurait dû
préciser que ce n'était pas payée en
fait c'est juste qu'elle vous a
tellement qui fait qu'à la fin poste
c'est ça exactement
mais les humains elle va revenir très
bon elle était a priori enfin du moins
je souhaite franchement alors vous ça
vous a fait une pub de fou oui on s'y
attendait pas ouais mais ça bloque
depuis ce matin s'arrête pas menacé m
toutes les tout mais c'est brice offense
aux médias par macha met un ballon on en
prend déjà de la merde
il ya des choses beaucoup plus important
les cheveux de de madame
ai-je d'appareils bien voilà madame
comment madame ciapa et non mais est ce
que vous comprenez la polémique
là-dessus maintenant oui on a dit
qu'elle avait payé tout ça sur vous la
comprenez ce que guillaume dans non ma
chance jusque maintenant mi chemin entre
elles est très fort pour faire de la com
ce qu'à chaque fois qu'elle fait des
choix pour voir d'elle à chaque fois
qu'elle vient sur une émission à chaque
fois que le faire poste instagram
le seul petit problème avec elle c'est
qu'on sait pas vraiment ce qu'elle fait
de par son poste en fait elle est
ministre de la citoyenneté est ce que
vous savez qui était son prédécesseur
non c'est non il y en avait pas parce
que c'est un poste été créé pour être
choqué il ya un petit problème de
positionnement comme elle est très forte
en tout cas bien mais nicolas je
comprends pas du tout en plus on connaît
la vérité maintenant donc c'est ridicule
de toujours polémiquer sur les prix
n'ont pas existé moncaut penser qu'elle
va parvenir à cause de ça j'espère pas
vous avez besoin de son cheveu ne soit
pas besoin de vrais noms mais comme je
crois que ce sera la france a besoin de
lissage c'était important de le signaler
on a ramené la facture on a remis les
choses au clair
si on vous dit combien ça coûte